a new hotel development is in the works
for downtown henderson and the owner of
the pass casino is hoping to put this
new hotel right next to a casino which
is over on water street and atlantic way
mary jane bellies is sharing the plans
and what it will bring to the water
street district
a new hotel could soon take over part of
the parking lot at the pass casino in
henderson joseph d simone the owner of
the pass says the project is currently
in the administrative design review
stage and is working with hotel brand
ihg to create the second atwell suites
in the country there'll be a wine bar in
front by the water street
and there'll be a two two story lounge
area
in the front of the hotel building
there will be 90 rooms most of them
suites
it will accommodate the the hockey arena
and the families that go there it will
accommodate all the incredible amount of
traffic water street gets especially
during the weekends desimone says
building a hotel has always been top of
mind not just to complement the past
casino but a growing area too he is now
preparing to submit the plans to the
city of henderson for approval for
pacific diner owner marvin wallace new
growth means more customers
areas
growing pretty much every week every
month every day
i mean we've had lots of restaurants
come in lots of bars come in it's great
it's all helping the area grow and
become a lot more popular redevelopment
manager anthony malloy with the city of
henderson says they are excited to
welcome the new hotel as it'll help
house tourists and bring in foot traffic
i think that many people haven't been to
water street in a long time maybe even a
decade and so what they can expect is
really to see a transformation from what
they had previously
seen and experienced to what it is today
reporting from water street and atlantic
avenue mary jane balleza live local now